[Music]
you know one of the most important
chapters in establishing our present
existence so to speak or present media
existence was the realization of the
power of the check in that is that urge
maybe you felt it I gotta check my email
or maybe I should see what's going on in
my Twitter stream or it's time to go to
Facebook it's kind of an unusual thing I
don't know how you'd explain it to
another generation but it's kind of
almost like a biological feeling that
you need to you know check in I would
say it was invented sometime in the
1970s with email and the first emails in
fact the first email addict in my
reading was a man named Steven Lukasik
who was the head of the ARPA agency in
the Pentagon in the early 1970s he was
an interesting guy because he carried
around what was then a portable computer
in the 70s this huge terminal and he
would plug it in everywhere he went and
he would check his email and he insisted
everyone do it and he was the first guy
who had what many of us have right now
which is just this almost addiction to
checking in now it's the psychology
behind it as interesting it is very
reminiscent of what BF Skinner described
as operant conditioning that is to say
that the tendency of all creatures not
just humans but pigeons and other
animals to take actions that will lead
to rewards you know pecking out a little
button to get a little snack but one of
the things that Skinner noticed I think
is very relevant for our lives is the
most addictive forms of rewards are
those that are unpredictable and so for
example if you Peck every time and out
comes a little prize well that's not
that interesting it's the things that
you can't predict whether there's slot
machines whether it's fishing whether
it's playing golf all the things that
like actually really capture our
interest are things where the reward
payout is quite unpredictable an email
obviously has set quality so does
Facebook most
the time you show up there's nothing
much there but occasionally you might
see something extraordinary an email
with great news or maybe a picture a
very meaningful message you know you go
log into social media most of the time
it's kind of a bore but occasionally
something quite profound is there and
this turns out to be the most addictive
kind of thing these unpredictable reward
schemes and I think there's a sense in
which we are little pigeons sitting
inside our boxes pecking away I mean
this is not the most inspiring model of
humanity but sometimes it is Oh like
that pecking away and and waiting to see
what rewards come to us and that is
proven to be a very addictive I don't
know if it's the right word but very a
compelling scheme and one which I think
many of us have gotten involved in
[Music]